So don't want to be a person is the
point of no return.
Dr Peterson,
when we look at what's happening in the
US,
I don't think we're at the point of no
return.
I don't think that things are more
fractious than they were in the 19
sixties.
You know,
there were plenty of riots in the 19
sixties.
There was a lot of racial tension,
there was a lot of social upheaval.
I don't even think we're at that.
I don't even think that the level of
social upheaval that we're experiencing
right now is at that level of magnitude.
But I think it is higher than it's been
at any point since the 19 sixties.
And I think the problem is is that the
postmodern radical types have got a
stranglehold on the administrative level
of many institutions.
But I think what they're going to find
is that the rug is going to be pulled
out from underneath them in ways they
don't expect.
So for example,
as the press has become,
let's say more ideologically
oriented,
the CBC is a good example of that.
I mean,
I used to like the CVC,
I've been,
I was treated more unprofessionally by
the CBC,
I would say this year.
Then by any other media organization
that I've been in contact with anywhere
in the world which is saying something
and multiple times,
not just once.
And I've never,
I mean I'm not complaining about that,
I'm just pointing it out.
But what's going to happen is that as
the media becomes more ideologically
committed,
it's going to become irrelevant faster
and faster.
And I think the same thing's gonna
happen with the education system,
the public education system,
and maybe even the universities,
the harder they push in the ideological
direction,
the faster technological transformation
we'll pull the rug out from underneath
their feet.
And I think that could happen.
Like I think that the,
the,
uh,
the classic news media,
so to speak,
his dad for anyone under 40,
certainly for anyone under 30.
So.
And so that actually.
Yeah.
Well then you can just see it.
If you pay any attention to youtube
where you have the rise of people like
Joe Rogan who gets a one point $8,
million downloads a year and use these
long format interviews of three hours
where you can go into things in depth,
so I'm not.
I'm less worried than I was a year ago.
I would say because what I've seen
happening is that there are many ways
that systems can be pulled out from
underneath the people who are attempting
to manipulate them and I think that
there's a diverse enough range of people
out there who are smart enough and fast
enough on their feet so that
the institutions that have become
corrupt will just die.
That's what it looks like to me.
Now.
That doesn't mean that we're not in.
For some rocky times.
We are the shake out in the public
education system is going to be
seriously ugly over the next five years
when as parents and teachers
increasingly wake up to the degree that
that they ideological domination has
occurred.
I guess what worries me is all the hr
departments and the direction that
they're leaning,
and even at our event,
some people have brought their syllabus
as in just show me they read,
always studying and I was reading them.
First of all,
these syllabuses are pages long A.
I remember mine were only like a page
long or two and it was just all sorts of
things like queer theory and radical
black feminist theory and this and that,
and when they graduate they're going to
be teachers.
Yeah.
Well the problem with those sorts of
approaches is that they're actually not
good for anything and so I think that if
you're marketing education that doesn't
educate,
that people will stop buying it a lot
faster than you think the universities
are still running on there previously
established reputation,
but they're making so many mistakes
right now that I think they're right
for,
for painful transition.
I mean there's already speculation in
the US that thousands of universities
and colleges are going to go bankrupt
over the next 10 years.
Okay.